pushing the basketball and making you
pay the price on the offensive end
how standing delivers who's had an
outstanding season for the Celtics
scoreless so far tonight curry wide open
first bucket for curry missed his first
four shots and that puts the Warriors
back up one hurry back out Livingston
Steph Curry's back-to-back threes for
comfy find the line with the speed that
he does but whoever taught him taught
him well
Perry tries it in putz ahead step hurry
four straight three pointers and : state
opens up a 7 7 point lead time time
great shooter and not just shooting the
basketball but the ability to make plays
look at the fine as Linda's some curry
was so quiet early on but underrated
strength hope struggled at times would
put pressure on it on the team when they
began to play their best basketball
because when both guys got in better
shape and got help and the roll was wide
open no support from the weak side and a
very weak trap as well
I mean this is just tremendous defense
and the ability to stay up Thomson
stolen by Heyward
Irving back for Horford puts up the
three knocks it down
well we cut so on premier defender and
klay Thompson the ability to creat big
addala guarding Irby
drives inside scoop shot back servo
laura's check for Irving the magician
with the ball